welcome to sas talks money where all we
talk is money i'm your host adam
selznick and i'm here to help you
build your wealth and to save that money
on today's episode we're breaking down
the six principles of wealth let's talk
money all we talk is
[Music]
so there's a problem here in america i
love america i'm all about capitalism
i'm all about everything usa but there
is a problem and within the education
system here it is
we all go to school we all take the same
useless classes
algebra biology chemistry trigonometry
no money classes
what's up with that no money classes so
i've set on a mission
to simplify money and find out exactly
what you need to know when it comes to
money and here's what i've uncovered the
key to money is understanding these
six principles of wealth so before we
get going on these six principles of
wealth i'm going to ask you a question
if you were chilling
with money i'm talking chilling like a
villain what would you be doing
with your free time answer that before i
continue think about
what would you be doing if you were
chilling with money do you have an
answer does something pop into your head
does some glaring answer come out
if not you need to reassess what you're
doing so here's my point before you can
figure out where you're going you need
to figure out where you want to end
up and the goal is to end up chilling
with money
the goal is to end up chilling with
money so you can win
the money game and that's right money is
a game so step number one
in these six principles of wealth is
developing a game plan
for your money so what'd you think about
what came to mind was it some
exotic island you want to travel to was
it something that you're super
passionate about spending your time
was it a cause that you care about what
came to mind so what we're going to do
is we're going to get to chilling at the
end but i want you to keep that in mind
of where you want to end up so what
we're going to do right now
is develop a game plan to get you to
where you want to end up and in the
money world
a budget is a game plan for your money
so now that you know where you want to
end up
let's develop a game plan to get you
there so before we get started
on really what's going on with your
budget let's just answer a simple
question
what is a budget budget is pretty simple
i even have a piece of paper here to
show you how
simple a budget can be boom piece of
paper
draw a line down the middle on one side
you have income and on the other side
you have expenses this is it
one piece of paper line down the middle
a budget the definition of a budget is
your income
minus your expenses let's do a deep dive
into what your budget looks like boom
you got income and you got expenses so
basically i play sports i don't know if
you play sports but basically here's how
i would look at
a budget and income and expenses income
is offense how much money you making
how much money is coming through the
door how many points are you putting up
on the board
expenses is like defense you want to
limit the amount of points that are
going
out the door you want to limit how much
money you're spending
every month so here's the deal a lot of
people will tell you when budgeting you
got to cut out your little minor
expenses
and don't buy that latte and it's not
worth spending 11
on netflix here's the deal i'm more
concerned about your net worth
not your netflix let me say that again
i'm concerned about your net worth
not your netflix so let's break that
down what's net worth
net worth is the whole name of the game
y'all if you don't know what net worth
is
you are missing the point so check it
out net worth
are your total assets minus your
liabilities
so when you're doing a budget it's very
important to understand that it's all
about your net worth
why don't i care about your netflix
netflix is 10 bucks a month maybe it's
11 maybe it's 12 i don't know they're
raising their prices but those are minor
expenses what i want you to focus on
are your big three expenses so what are
your big three expenses
everybody has the exact same big three
expenses number one is your housing
now housing should not be more than 33
of your entire
budget 25 to 33 to be exact number two
biggest expense transportation 10 to 20
you should not exceed that at all this
is where i see a lot of people losing
car payments car insurance just money
going out the door a lot of people
losing that way
number three is what i call f and b food
and beverage
are you eating out are you bringing your
lunch to work are you cooking at home
are you drinking on the weekends are you
buying bottles at clubs this is
f and b you got to understand that this
needs to be below 10
of your total income so my friends
here's what let me just back up a second
here
boom boom boom housing transportation
food and beverage once you've done those
three
i've got good news for you you're now 75
of the way done
with your entire budget now from there
you can back up
and figure out the minor expenses that
may be weighing you down your cell phone
bill
apps netflix to be clear but a lot of
people will tell you to cut out your
minor expenses uh-uh i want you to focus
on your big
three expenses now here let's just back
it up again there's something in the
budgeting world called the 50
30 20 rule now what does this mean this
is an overall
concept for your budgeting right and
here's what it is 50 of your income
should go to your needs
30 should go to your wants and 20 should
go to saving
and or paying off debt which we're gonna
cover in principle two and three so
understand that there's a big picture
name to this game
and understanding the 50 30 20 rule as
an overall concept is important to
understand so let me wrap this all
up and give you some key takeaways here
so i used to listen to hip-hop back in
the day i still listen to hip-hop
and there was a song that blew my mind
and made me understand the money game
when i was a teenager and the song was
from a group called
bone thugs and harmony do you remember
that group and they had a huge hit song
and the song went like this
wake up wake up wake up it's the first
of the month
and i remember being a kid and being
like what goes down on the first of the
month
friends do mother sucker so you
understand that rents due on the first
of the month so what i encourage you to
do is understand on the first of the
month is when you need to be doing your
budget
last takeaway with budgeting and here's
a big picture with budgeting again
sports guy here i gave you some offense
and defense here's my analogy for you
who is the greatest football player of
our generation
you don't have to think long about that
who is it the goat tom brady
now here's what i respect about tom
brady he's not the biggest he's not the
fastest he's not the strongest he might
be the best looking but
what does he do before every single game
is he has a game plan him and bill
belichick
i know he's uh you know obviously on
tampa bay these days but him
and bill belichick had a game plan for
every single game he didn't just show up
and be like all right i guess we're
going to
beat the jets today no he knew exactly
how he was going to beat the jets so
what's the analogy for you what's the
metaphor here you need to go into
every single month of the first of the
month like our friends bone thugs and
harmony pointed out and you need to have
a budget for every single month
so that's it a budget does not need to
be that complicated it can be as simple
as a sheet of paper you can use an app
you can use an excel spreadsheet but at
the end of the day it's this
understand your income understand your
expenses limit your big three expenses
and that is budgeting like brady so now
that we've developed a game plan for
your money it's time to move on to
principle number two so before you can
win
the money game don't lose and debt my
friends
debt is your money going backwards now
in my opinion
the worst four-letter word in the world
is debt
i don't give a a mother it's a piece of
no word in the world is worse than debt
debt as you can see in red debt is what
is known as losing
the interest rate game as we discussed
if money's a game money's a game you got
to have a game plan for your money don't
lose the interest rate game debt is your
money going backwards so the number one
question i ask people that have debt i
ask them this question what's the
interest rate and often they look at me
like
i don't man i don't even know i don't
know the interest rate how do you not
know the interest rate that is your
money going backwards and you're
losing the interest rate game so here
let's break this down
understanding what a good interest rate
it is a bad interest rate game we're
gonna break down the interest rate game
okay so debt is your money going
backwards we're gonna discuss what
winning the interest rate game looks
like
and soon enough but understanding that
in the interest rate game there's what i
call the seas
of debt all these bad words four letter
words
all these bad words start with the
letter c let's break it down
you got credit cards you got college
loans you got car loans you got cash
advances
you got cribs aka mortgages you got
credit scores
you got consumer debt and the big one
overall consumerism so let's take a deep
dive into these
four letter words and see how bad they
really are all right credit cards
average credit card balance in america
today
fifty seven hundred dollars do you have
credit card debt do you understand the
interest rate that you're paying
average college loan right now thirty
five thousand dollars student loans
average car payment in america right now
four to five hundred dollars five
hundred dollars for
a new car 400 will round up for a used
car do you understand
that these car payments are killing you
cash advances the average rate on the
low end
23 you might get a payday loan that the
interest rate is four
to five hundred percent cash advances
payday loans killing you crips
like people call them mortgages
sometimes you get into a mortgage you
don't even understand how bad the debt
is and how bad you're drowning
crips the average amount uh mortgage
debt that has owed 200
000 average credit score in america
right now credit score is 700 that's a
good credit score
let me tell you none of this is good
average amount of consumer debt in
america this is the
average american has a hundred and
thirty seven thousand dollars
of consumer debt so add this all up boom
boom boom boom boom
consumerism is killing you the name of
the game is becoming a saver
and an investor so you can become what
chilling and we're going to get you to
chilling but understand that you need to
develop a payoff plan
to get out of debt now when it comes to
debt you got two options for a payoff
plan you got what is known as the
debt snowball and the debt avalanche
pick a plan i don't care which one you
go with but you got to pick a plan now
what is the debt snowball
the debt snowball just picture a
snowball
you work from their smallest debt you
work your way up to your medium-sized
debt and then you tackle your largest
debt
last so it's the amount of debt that you
go from smallest first to your middle
debt to your largest debt
last okay now what is the debt avalanche
that avalanche is saying hey man i'm
getting
killed on the interest rate game so
rather than start with the smallest i'm
going to start with the largest
highest interest rate that i'm paying so
as an example if you're paying
400 on a cash advance get that out of
your life homie so those are your two
different payoff plans you get a debt
snowball
and you got a debt avalanche but again
to recap this before you can win the
money game
don't lose and debt is your money going
backwards
now it's time to win and what i always
tell people is you need to
save that money saving
is the key to wealth now how did i
discover this it seems pretty obvious
but when i first started this show sas
talks money what i did
is i didn't have all the answers so i
went to every single financial advisor
every single financial professional i
dealt with and i interviewed them we
could probably roll the tape on how many
people i've interviewed
and i asked them one question i said
what's your biggest piece of advice
for millennials when it comes to money
number one
save to invest right ninety percent of
the time they said hey they need to be
saving that money so i said okay i get
it you need to save that money and then
what did i do after that i started
interviewing all the young people in
america
20 and 30 somethings and i was going to
concerts and festivals and all sorts of
fun places where young people hang out
and i asked them one question as well i
said
would you rather a or b
spend that money and what do you think
the most common response was
eighty percent of the time people say yo
spend that money
live it up who gives a crap do your
thing yolo
spend that money uh uh you're going in
the wrong direction if you have a spend
that money mentality the key to wealth
is saving and you need to have a
savers mentality now why do you need to
have a savers mentality what's so
important about saving well it gives you
a cushion unless life is perfect for you
and nothing ever happens
things happen in your life things happen
in your life where you need a cushion
to get you out of it so these terms are
interchangeable a cushion
a rainy day fund an emergency fund these
are all
terms that you should be familiar with
and this is money that you need to last
you six to 12 months god forbid
something happens
okay right now we're in the middle of
corona i can tell you straight up if you
did not save that money
you got another thing coming so here's
what i'll tell you cash is king that has
never
been more clear than today let me read
you a couple different stats and then
i'm going to give you a piece of advice
so stats on this side
this is what i call the not so fun stats
of americans live paycheck to paycheck
let me say that again
75 percent of americans live paycheck to
paycheck and i actually just saw a stat
today that it's actually 78
now so i gotta update that stat number
two sixty percent
don't have a thousand dollars to their
name what sixty percent of americans
name
forty percent don't have four hundred
dollars to cover an emergency
twenty five percent have no savings at
all and here's the kicker y'all here's
the kicker this will go back to the debt
part
ninety percent of americans buy things
they can't afford
okay let me say that again ninety
percent of americans buy
things they can't afford so here's my
advice to you before you try to win the
money
game before you're ready to move on to
investing before you're really really
trying to live your best life you need
to save ten thousand dollars
now some of you might say ten thousand
dollars that's no big deal i could do
that in one year cool
and some of you might be saying man i
don't even have a thousand dollars to my
name and there's the rub my friends
it's not easy to save this kind of money
but if it was easy everyone would do it
so my advice to you is save
ten thousand dollars there's two ways to
have more money there's only two ways to
have more money you can either make more
or you can spend less
let me say that again you can either
make more or spend less and here's what
the wealthy do you ready for the secret
they do bone they make more and they
spend less it's not that complicated
there's no secret to this
biggest piece of advice live on less
than you make you make fifty thousand
dollars a year
live on 48 of it save two thousand
dollars if you can't
live on less than you make you're never
gonna get ahead you're never gonna save
and you're never
gonna get to principal number four so
now that we've saved that money it's
time to move on to principle number four
which is investing now you're ready to
invest
that money here's the key difference
between saving and investing
saving is short term this is money
you're going to need in the next year or
two investing is long
term this is long growth now what is
investing so investing actually is
pretty simple there's only two parts to
investing that you need to understand
time and compound interest time and
compound interest is what investing
is all about so compound interest if
you're not familiar with this this
is the eighth wonder of the world this
is winning
the interest rate game compound interest
is your money making money
on money making money on money making
money like it's just it's the exact
opposite of your money going backwards
so just to understand how
lethal debt is backing up a little bit
compound interest can either work
for you in investing or work against you
with debt so if i'm telling you the key
to investing and getting wealthy
is utilizing compound interest that's
what's working against you when you have
debt so
understand the interest rate game here
this is red
this is green this is where you want to
be so understanding the compound
interest the eighth wonder of the world
you want that on your side that's your
amigo that's your compadre you don't
want that against
you you don't want him fighting against
you how do you win the interest rate
game well it's not that complicated we
talked about time and compound interest
let's talk about time
long term strategy there's something
called buy and hold
delayed gratification good things take
time there's no
get rich quick scheme over here anyone
who tells you they got some brilliant
idea where you can get rich in the next
six to 12 months
run the other way y'all investing takes
time
and compound interest to understand that
when you're investing you want your
assets
to appreciate right you don't want
depreciation which is kind of like
debt depreciating right you buy a car
it's worth 20 grand today how much is
that car worth in five years
way less than twenty thousand dollars
probably closer to five thousand dollars
now think about it if you buy a mutual
fund when it comes to investing if
you're not familiar with mutual funds
we'll do a deep dive in another episode
about it just what investing is
but if you're not familiar with that a
mutual fund you buy it today you look at
it in five years
it's gone up significantly so understand
the difference between appreciation
and depreciation so i'll ask you a
personal question would you rather be
appreciated or depreciated would you
rather someone come up to you and say
hey man you're looking good hey
pretty fit all right yeah but looking
good buddy hey hey honey you're looking
you lost some weight it's appreciation
or man you look like crap yeah you
man you ain't [ __ ] man that's
depreciation same
thing with investing being appreciated
debt
depreciation know the difference so now
let's get into it the
the technical side of investing in my
opinion you got three options and then a
fourth option which we'll cover as well
option number one you got the stock
market and if you're gonna invest in the
stock market i got a perfect place for
you to start
at work you probably got a 401k plan if
you don't know about that you should
look into it especially if it has what
is called a match
matches free money now if you don't have
a 401k plan at work you can go to your
bank you can go to an online bank and
you can look into something called a
roth ira so there's your two options if
you're like dude what's the point where
we going with this
you can look into a 401k or a roth ira
check those two things out that's where
you can begin
investing component number two if you're
like look i'm not really a stock market
kind of person i don't get it i don't
really understand it
i'm more of a real estate type of person
that's cool too that's a separate thing
but there's a difference between taking
on a mortgage debt and hoping that your
real estate appreciates that's a big
difference between investing in real
estate properties and
income and cash flow type properties is
a big difference so understand that when
you're investing in real estate
it's not as simple as yeah i bought real
estate and i'm making money ask anyone
in real estate it's not
that easy okay option number three and
this could be the biggest payoff
if you know what you're doing is
starting a business becoming an
entrepreneur investing in yourself
taking a risk big big payoff but it
ain't easy ask
any entrepreneur out there they'll tell
you that they it's a 24
7 job it ain't easy here's the fourth i
want you to listen closely now
i don't care if you pick stock market
real estate
starting a business you can do all three
if you want to diversify but the one
thing you have to do the one thing that
you can't afford to not do
is invest in yourself that means this i
want you to get smarter i want you to
get sharper i want you to get sexier i
want you to get quicker
everything that you want to become is
investing
in yourself now the key component with
that is investing
your time wisely the biggest change in
my life
was understand the difference between
spending time
and investing time i used to spend a lot
of time
bs in south beach and it was until i
understood the difference between
investing my time wisely that i
understood okay
i'm investing in myself now and that as
warren buffett says is the best
investment you can ever make but here's
the best analogy that i can give you
with investing it's just like planting a
tree
if you're gonna plant the seeds and give
it some water and give it some sunlight
it's gonna take
time to grow but if you're looking at it
every single day why isn't my tree
growing and
then you pick up the tree and you plant
it someplace else and then you move it
to another city and hopefully that
it's sunny you're there it's just that's
not how it works plant the seeds
give it water invest your time wisely
watch the tree grow and in no time
you'll be chilling the tree over your
head chilling in the shade all right so
now we're on to principle number five
which is insure and insurance is simply
protection so let me ask you a question
before we get really into the insurance
stuff what is your biggest asset i'm
asking you
what is your biggest asset is it your
house is it your car
is your computer is it your phone is it
your boat what's your biggest asset
if you did not say yourself then you
missed the answer here
you are your biggest asset your ability
to work
earn a living paychecks income
your ability to make money is your
biggest
asset insurance protection health is
wealth
you are your biggest asset health is
wealth let's stop right there
what happens if you get sick what
happens if god forbid something even
worse happens to you what happens to
your family so let's break down what i
call
the real big three number one
your health do you have health insurance
number two
life insurance if you have a family if
you've got kids what happens if you
don't make it home tonight do you have
life insurance pretty intense question
right there but god
have you ever asked yourself that what
happens if you don't make it home
tonight tell me who's someone who's
lived forever nobody so one of these
days we're all going to meet our demise
what's going to happen if you meet yours
and you have no insurance in place
to protect your family number three
disability insurance
you're way more likely to get hurt
disabled not able to work than to die
thank goodness
but what happens if now you're alive
home in bed and you can't do anything
break your back you have cancer you fall
off a ladder i have a friend of mine who
went wakeboarding he was an electrician
went wakeboarding used to love
wakeboarding on the weekends
rope gets ripped off rope gets tied
around his hand his hand gets ripped off
what
dude was an electrician now he's got one
hand he's alive but he can't work
you ever seen a one-handed electrician
doesn't work that way so this is the
real
big three i know so many people that got
car insurance
and renters insurance but they got no
health insurance they got no life
insurance they got no disability
insurance so let me let me just back up
because i'm getting a little tense here
now but sometimes you got to be to get
drive a point home
the number one cause of bankruptcy in
america the number one cause is medical
bills
that's the number one cause you get sick
you get injured you go to the hospital
you got no insurance
can't pay your bills it's an ugly
situation so understand that the most
important thing you can do
is take care of your health health is
wealth and why do you need to do that
why do you need to do that because you
know what happens [ __ ] happens
straight up people drive around with
bumper stickers back in the day [ __ ]
happens so understand that things happen
in your life you have no
control over i was dating a girl for a
long time i thought we'd get married
boom 24 years old cancer what thank god
she had health insurance so i've seen it
firsthand that if you don't have
insurance
the ramifications and the bankruptcy
that could happen in your life so
principle number five
health is wealth and make sure that you
are insured
now we're on to principle number six
which is chilling
we're we're back where we started at the
beginning you remember when i asked you
at the very beginning of this segment
what would you do with your free time
if you were chilling if you had millions
in the bank i asked you
what would you do if you were chilling
what did you say do you remember did you
write it down
where you at chillin is when you own
your time you do what you want this is
also known as financial freedom what
this was also known as back in the day
was retirement now retirement is an
antiquated term we can go on a whole
conversation about why retirement does
not really exist anymore okay the
concept of
sitting at a beach in a rocking chair
and waiting to die does not exist
anybody who's made it in life doesn't
just do nothing
people stay doing something so i ask
people all the time
if you were chilling what would you do
with your free time you want to know
what the three most
common responses are number one people
want to travel they want to see the
world hell yeah
we all want to do that number two they
want to pursue a passion
something that they love they would do
for free whether that's art whether
that's photography whether that's
stand-up comedy whether that's
any single thing that you're passionate
about you would love to do that if you
had more time number three
people want to give back people want to
donate their time
to causes that they care about totally
understand that
those are the three most common
responses and why are you doing all this
what is the whole point of all this
budgeting and getting out of debt and
saving and investing why are you doing
all this
it's to hopefully leave a legacy
something that's bigger
than you to create something that's
bigger than yourself the great people i
know and i asked them so here's the
here's my final take i would interview
all these millionaires and billionaires
and these hedge funds execs and
just people who just completely crushed
it and i said listen guys after you made
the money you invested the money and you
killed it like what's next
what's next and they all said legacy
they said legacy planning planning for
generations so right now you might be
struggling you might have no money right
now
you might be living paycheck to paycheck
like 75 of america but if you don't have
a game plan for your money and you don't
know where you want to end up
you're missing the boat so hopefully
these six principles resonated with you
hopefully you got something from this
because the goal is to be chilling with
money not so you can sit there and do
nothing and so you can do as much of
this
as you want to do so the key to all this
the key to all this
is you might have guessed it save that
money
so that was the six principles of wealth
let me give you a quick recap
a budget is a game plan for your money
debt is your money going backwards
saving is the key to wealth investing is
growing your money over time
insurance is protecting your biggest
asset which is you
and chilling which is the name of the
game is when you can own
your time now if you haven't seen my
first video about stimulus checks and
the cares act
make sure to check it out right here so
thanks for watching and if you've not
subscribed to valuetainment money
please click below right there and as
always
save that money all we talk is money